we have a nutrition crisis on our hands
we need more fresh food closer to cities
new ways of growing food that conserve
soil and we shouldn't just keep spending
money the way we have been today I'm
speaking with Ken Cook the president and
co-founder of environmental working
group at least 200 million Americans
have past chemicals in their finished
drinking water right out of the tap at a
level that we consider unsafe we cover
specific ways all of us can make better
more formed decisions about the choices
we make at the market taking advantage
of the many resources and guides that
ewg provides it was an honor to host a
conversation I think you will find quite
edifying there are definitely things you
can do personally to
dramatically reduce your personal
exposure to these
chemicals like what are we supposed to
actually pay attention to well I
mean